[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
my guest today is a very funny
professional comic matthew broussard
he's been on the tonight show conan jeff
ross rose battle he has a comedy central
half hour he just got done opening for
burke christian on the road and above
all that he's the first ever guest on
the joke world podcast your new favorite
comedy podcast is coming to you every
single wednesday on all platforms make
sure you go download and subscribe and
follow on spotify and the podcast app
and all that stuff and comment what
other comedians you want me to interview
we're going all around the country
interviewing your favorite comedians for
this channel and for youtube we got some
great guests lined up next week in
austin so make sure you stay tuned joke
world podcast it's your new favorite
podcast and with no further ado matthew
broussard i want to welcome to tampa
performing at side splitters this
weekend and one of the first ever guests
on the joke world podcast matthew
brassard hello joke world my name is
matthew
thank you for being here thank you so
much dude picked you up at the whole
foods and uh got up here bang out a
podcast real quick yeah i can eat my
salad bar with no fork i'm just going to
eat the rice uh grain by grain so why do
people [ __ ] on tampa so much
see i don't know i didn't know that
people [ __ ] on tampa dude it was it's
like a thing it was the punchline you
could just use tampa as a punchline
mm-hmm
for what like neil brennan i remember
there's a neil brennan joke
he was like people
people leaving negative comments on like
bach
on like
beethoven like this sucks bro and i know
music i'm from tampa i remember that and
i remember just like a bunch of people
use tampa it's just it's just like a
great city it used to be cleveland kind
of like the bro city well that's where
i'm from that's what i was going to say
i'm used to
maybe people [ __ ] on the city that
i'm from
cleveland i mean just take the abuse no
questions
it's almost like at least someone's
talking about us you know
all policy is good publicity i guess
yeah you could be like uh
somewhere what minneapolis no one even
jokes about them that's just as shitty
as cleveland no there's there's there's
jokes about every city minneapolis fat
but the weird thing is about 10 i moved
here eight months ago
i didn't know that was a punchline i
didn't know it was a joke i've been
having a fantastic time here yeah if
anything but i never thought about tampa
beforehand growing up in ohio it was
just like it's in florida whatever yeah
didn't have any really preconceived
feeling of it yeah florida is the
punchline state
as a punchline for anything kind of
grimy or or uh
almost stupid in a way
or i mean florida out there yeah floor
the florida man yeah i guess stupid
isn't even the right word drugged up
yeah what's okay what's the most florida
city
the first thing that came to mind was
jacksonville oh that's a good answer the
word is dirty it's like long and it's
like yeah it has like an x sound in it
that's a good answer that's pretty far
north though isn't it yeah so which
means it's more southern
right culturally
right it's diverse right
lake city where's lake city
okay
i guess i might not be the best person
even i guess you're new learning about
lake city florida is a mix though that's
the thing that makes florida interesting
well that's so funny because when i
first moved here i'm like in the
downtown place it's like beach this is
the bougie area
right you can't see out the window we
got a high school on a river
it's a nice jesus it's a nice little
view and i expected this to be like
florida spring break is what i thought i
was moving to and it is like that a lot
of from where i'm kind of running into
you know i'm still going out a lot
you know my kind of circles but then if
you drive a little too far in in the
wrong direction it turns into like the
south like i forget that this is also
floor like i completely forget about
that and sometimes i'm reminded of it
when i see like some
some pickup trucks that are almost like
touching the ground on the back with
just some dishwashers and stuff in the
back and just like you know scrappers
that pick up [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere
like you'll see some real florida [ __ ]
every once in a while and be like oh
yeah
oh yeah i am south
i during the pandemic i drove from
atlanta to south florida i think i did
that ride in either direction four times
um the billboards at the florida georgia
line
get real crazy a lot of pro-life and
then you'll know these if you ever made
this this road trip um there's
christian signs it's like jesus
iscoming.net and there's a bunch of them
and they're really old there's like at
least five of them and we checked it out
no one owns that website currently
so at least it's it's someone needs to
buy it and turn it into a planned
parenthood page or something just have
some fun that's like such like a silver
platter an alley-oop of a joke if you
got a little disposable income and can
buy that also i mean how old are you how
old are you that you think someone's
going to see a billboard and type in a
website and all the people that would
would do that would be so old that they
don't even know how to do that right
[ __ ] put a qr code on it that's yeah
that's safer let me go yeah
that's that drive that's so funny we
went me and my roommate drove up to uh
nashville a few maybe a month ago
and it's like florida you know when you
get in between because florida you can
go 50 miles over the speed limit that's
the thing in the florida highway and you
kind of fear for your life a little bit
and no one else seems to care about
their life that's one of the that's some
crazy that is
florida florida is [ __ ] you i'm gonna do
me yeah yeah and good luck but then
after that you know when you're in
georgia because you go the speed limit
because those cops snipe you and the
billboards get insane the billboards are
it's not even like what they're saying
it's like they're every five yards from
one another down the entire
state
there's ones for like
like religious what was it it was like
jesus zombie there's a there's a crazy
one there's jesus jesus zombie one and
it's like you can pull over to like this
jesus that rob zombie son
might be
he's he's the uh the chosen one he's a
christian yeah christian death rock yeah
it's it's aggressive
it is it's the georgia billboard
community they don't care about they're
not uh as many restrictions
yeah what is the most ohio
city hmm
because i this is
i love to ask this question what's the
most generic city in america
and my answer is columbus ohio wow i
don't mean that as an insult i'm just
saying if you wrote a sitcom there yeah
you wouldn't have to worry about how the
culture would affect right i was gonna
say columbus as in like
what's what city is like all encompasses
the the feeling of i'm in ohio the most
but
like there's so many different
perspectives i guess some people think
it's like uh corn and like farming and
that's not really columbus so i i was
kind of trying to figure out how to
maybe answer that but i guess columbus
would be uh because that's like
you got the college there obviously big
convention center it's a convention
center it's like the fast food capital
of america or something like people go
there to like test out if their fast
food works it's like a big marketing
so they have like wendy's headquarters
they have like some
but as far as just like normal people go
you get the beta burger you get to see
what it's like before it hits the market
yeah all that impossible whopper stuff
whoa
um
but yeah so i guess it is just kind of a
normal normal place but i like cleveland
because you get lake erie too and that
seems very ohio to me see ohio for me
because cleveland's north is like oh uh
like lake erie in the summer that kind
of thing which i guess is not very ohio
if you've talked to someone that's never
been there like what they would think
you probably wouldn't say water or like
ohio might be the most generic state
yeah yeah
very there's just like not much of
anything going on but also not they're
not missing
too much but there's not over
much yeah
yeah yeah in cleveland did hilarities a
few times and then great club yeah
really good club i performed there in
2016 i did a weekend
and um i was staying at the hotel right
across the way downtown and on sunday
there was a note slipped under my door
that says the rnc starts tomorrow
all hotels are sold out in the whole
region for the week you cannot extend
your stay you must
yeah you must be out of here evacuate
the premise like that is the most
republican thing you could have done i
also learned this about uh that week
when the rnc comes to town all of the
bars get to extend their closing hour to
four
because there's so much partying and
coke and drinks wow and apparently it is
busy season for male prostitutes i mean
female prostitutes too
but there's a lot of like you know
lindsey graham types they're like i'm
gonna have me a little
little pieces tonight wow i never would
have thought that i would have thought
these were some old dudes that were
boring as [ __ ] and that's what they'd
love you to think yeah yeah they're
doing a great job listen i'm sure
democrats party real hard too but we're
just not as fun as republicans and that
is hilarious the only thing i remember
from being there during that time was
that was the year that the cavs won the
the nba finals and i was at the watch
party in game seven when they came back
from that one three lead one the
greatest nights of my life and greatest
accomplishments that i've ever had was
watching my team
win that championship but i was yeah i
was in the everyone gets hands jobs
tonight everyone gets hand jobs that was
the second busiest time for mail
processes
but i was in the stadium and or the the
arena during the watch party because
during the game
it was away it was in california and so
they filled up the whole arena with fans
watching on the big screen but the court
was all set up
for the for the rnc so like it was like
big stages and like
it just kind of ruined the moment to be
like we're all watching the game but
then you look at the court and it's just
like weird just like set up for
for something that's not basketball it
did kind of take you out of it a little
bit but then you went outside afterwards
and it was mayhem a million people right
yeah at the parade million people that's
one thing that people ask me about how
is the parade million people machine gun
kelly is hanging off the is he from
cleveland yeah yeah he is yeah yeah he
has a coffee shop there now it's kind of
kind of cringy actually it was cool at
the beginning but now girls will dress
to the nines and go there and and like
take pictures like standing in like hour
long lines outside of this coffee shop
and it's like one of the only
bougie places in cleveland it's the only
place trying to be bougie in cleveland
it's the only place that isn't a [ __ ]
factory so it's just kind of weird to
see like girls like in crop tops and
skirts at 9am just like
taking the same picture 40 times to get
the perfect one outside this coffee shop
in cleveland ohio it's it's bizarre
but yeah anyway that parade was
something that it was cool to be at but
it was miserable to actually attend it's
just something to be like yeah i was
there but during that day was terrible
you couldn't move you couldn't see
anything it was it was like fire festive
championship parades
is machine gun kelly cool
that's a good question do you think he's
cool i
there was a there's a timeline of no no
no yes
what inspired the yes
um probably before this latest phase of
like punk rock machine gun color oh sure
like more when he because i'm kind of
into that whole uh rap genre i'd say of
music when he was doing like
um his song candy with like trippy red
that kind of there was he had a few good
rap songs and some features where he was
like his whole vibe was different it was
like
a little grungy but not he was still
cool i guess i'm trying to describe
maybe a cool person for where i was at
my my age i'd say around 20 to
22 and a half i was like yeah that's
that's something that's cool not someone
that i was like he's so [ __ ] cool but
he was on that i'd be like i wouldn't
laugh at you if you were going to
machine gun kelly concert over the last
year i'm about to turn 24 over the last
year i would say
now it's like
i don't really get i don't really get it
as much yeah dude i'm 34. that'll happen
yeah you stop the
i don't know if you ever used a floppy
drive but there's like a thing you can
snap on it and it doesn't hold new
information anymore and that happens
with your music tastes like you got to
find a band
before you're 22.
or because i can't enjoy machine gun
kelly i don't get it it seems kind of
sorry buddy
it just it wasn't for me it never spoke
to me and i think it was just a little
too old for it i do like though that he
does wrap cleveland a lot which is
something i can appreciate because of
how much of a punch line it is that when
we get one one guy to be big it's like
thank you for not acting like you never
were from here yeah that's cool to me
but the other thing that his music it
changed from like cool rap that i liked
to like this new genre of like almost
asking to be depressed like if i'm in a
good mood why would i put on a machine
gun kelly song that's like kind of emo
and okay
that's what that music is really
appealing when you're at that age i mean
i assume you're an emo rap fan based on
the name of the pod
yeah i am a juice world i'm a big juice
guy yeah yeah but now it's like i guess
i liked the rap version of that maybe
not so much the uh the punk like
screaming
emo rap i i it on mathematically of
course it's going to be huge it mixes
the bravado of rap with the emotional
vulnerability of emo music i had those
two things separately growing up yeah
they did not cross streams and i liked i
liked from each pot i loved blink i
loved i guess my rappers were like
lil wayne was coming up around that time
so i loved um
so there was an iteration that i got to
see the beginning of which was i really
loved kid cudi i discovered
cleveland guy in college basically any
reps
shaker heights yeah yeah uh cleveland uh
wale who's more of like a conscious rap
yeah and uh drake and i discovered those
guys all
before i turned 24. probably before i
turned 22. that's and i like that
and i understand they're lame i
understand if you're older than me why
that would seem really dorky but i will
never stop appreciating what they did
yeah especially oh and then kanye was an
iteration of that kanye was vulnerable
in a way that rappers were afraid to be
and that was when i was in high school
and that was cool man his early stuff i
don't know if you've been watching the
doc or watch the doc but those early
like
graduation the driver albums yeah i mean
trio was [ __ ] i was i was alive for
that i was i've been re-listening to
that a lot recently
that is vulnerable that's like not
current rap of just like look how great
i am you could never do this look how
much money and there's always been that
and yeah there's always that and maybe
that he has a few songs like that but
most of these are just like
him talking about his actual life and
just this crazy perspective on things
that the wire the wire was his dropout
it was why
like no one is doing that kind of no one
cares about music i feel like how much
he did it seems like these current
rappers like little baby the baby all
these babies all they care about is
money making as much as that's not new
to get that's
like the baby if he wasn't good rapper
he would just do whatever he could to
make the most amount of money it seemed
like kanye if he was the worst rapper he
would still be a producer he would still
do whatever he could to be around music
that's so funny he seems like he loves
music for music for rappers
you sell out when you start caring about
something other than the money yeah like
like the ground level is i'm here to get
rich [ __ ] everything else in the second
like but what about artistry like
yeah
that is true that's such a reversal and
then there's a bit i did years ago but
yeah
rappers go broke bragging about how rich
they are and comedians get rich joking
about how broke they are yeah yeah yeah
there's something that or like comedians
are trying to convince you that they're
normal and like rappers are trying to
convince you that they're they're not or
something yes which is funny
and rappers succeed breaking those rules
or as comedians do comedians trying to
be cool
it will never work no i see i did that i
see so many young comics doing that to
be like you have to give up
and and what a wonderful thing that you
can indulge in you're not coolness you
don't have to fake something no one's
gonna like think that
no one wants to like laugh at you and
you be like this cool guy that has
nothing wrong with them and it's like
well then you're just you're you're a
douche dude you're winning everything
like you're being like look how sick i
am and now listen to me make you laugh
for an hour that doesn't even it's like
it's harder to be kevin hart than in a
lot of ways than it is to be maybe an
unknown in a lot of ways it isn't but
people know that you're super rich and
you have this different
perspective that you didn't have in in
your earlier days but i will say that
pete davidson seems pretty cool and if
he counts as a comedian i think he cares
about his jokes still yeah which goes a
long way and i think he is a [ __ ] up
person and yeah and we all know that so
it doesn't he he's still got a lot of
pain he's just being whatever he'd be
yeah he's not he's not trying to be cool
which i really appreciate yeah um
and let here's the thing we're talking
about comedians trying to be cool and
people listening are probably picturing
like bro like jesuit impressions there
is this on the far left side of comedy
as well there is this it it's it's funny
to see
someone going up and making i guess it's
called virtue signaling but just like
making making up stories where some
bigot says something and they they
one-up them of like yeah that's also
trying to be cool i know you're fighting
for a good cause i respect that but like
you you need to be the puncher you're
just trying to be cool in a different
new framework yeah that's like more
we'll see tweets
well i'm guilty by the way during the
trump administration like half of my
tweets were like yeah y'all are racist
well then maybe you have one of these
tweets that's like sure i do [ __ ] i was
so i'm so sorry to everything i tweeted
during the trump administration it's
over now you can take a deep breath
that's the other thing dude well i go i
want to get back to these guys tweets
but people like the late night shows i
feel like they are still making trump
jokes because now they don't know what
to talk about because four years there
was a whole sector of comedy that was
just like every week is just gonna be
jokes about the president now that's
gone
i just saw
i think jimmy kimmel is still making
trump jokes it's like i thought this was
over but now that's your lane i guess
i saw earthquake's new special he'd made
trump jokes that were very good but it's
his first special in a while right so he
wants to talk about it talked about it
from the black perspective from a
personal perspective it was good but
yeah
i also like i remember yourself in a way
i was like when i moved to l.a and i had
heat and no no nothing nothing
else just like a couple people thought i
had a chance and were
giving me opportunities i didn't deserve
but i had the chance to work for e
in some capacity and they're like make
jokes about pop culture i'm like i don't
want to make a joke about what ceelo
wore to the awards show because it's
already ridiculous yeah i don't like
making jokes about things that are
already absurd like to me great comedy
is
seinfeldian where it's like let's take
something that you think is mundane
and see how much you can wring it out
for absurdity yeah you want to make
people think how did i not think of that
yes more than yes
exactly wow that was right there and no
one saw it that's great to me yeah i do
this every day and this guy just pointed
out something completely something
everyone sees but no one notices yeah or
just like a different way to think about
things and i feel like that is a
different
a style of comedy that i enjoy a lot or
just like starting off as maybe an open
mic or you're like i'm going to write
these jokes they're going to be more
observational
especially because you get five minutes
usually no one knows who you are so a
personal story might not hit the same as
if you're an established person your
fans are coming out maybe you have a
podcast so people are used to hearing
these intimate details about you you can
tell a story about your family your kids
or your spouse or something because
people know all the characters and they
know you
i've always there's pre-records yeah
i've always thought i see a great
special or a great joke from someone
that i admire and it's a story and i'm
like man
i want to get a signature story or i
want to tell jokes like that instead of
these like set up punchline observation
kind of surface level
jokes but it seems like you can't start
like i just said you guys start off
building up your reputation so how as
someone who's really gone maneuvered the
waters have you ever cared about being
like i want to be a storyteller i've
always wanted to be a storyteller and
always failed yeah i mean yeah i can i
think i've hit two or three minutes with
a story but i know that i'm i'm kind of
patting it out with observational stuff
i think longest story i have was like
the pokemon sculpture story um
i like that one but i mean jay larson is
the the phone call i think it's one of
my top top five top ten late night sets
where it's just one story about a phone
call yeah which please check it out
that's yeah that's one if you're a
comedy fan yeah plug some stuff uh where
we can do top lane knight sets uh
goldman states abbreviations number one
i think i think nick vadarat
has my second favorite which is uh
i don't know what to call it uh just
google nick vadarat late night set i
won't say what the joke is because
there's one joke in it that makes it's
already a good it's already good stand
up and then he does something that just
takes it to such a higher level um that
prop meta comedy and it's it's that
stuff is so bad unless it's so good yeah
uh i love i love roy scovall's piano set
i think that was a really good one yeah
so i think one of my favorite sets ever
if we had to do favorite stand-up sets i
liked a lot of the this is not happening
show um and those are all kind of
stories i love chris stefano's 911 story
which by the way
[ __ ] chris because he put that out on
like 9 11. like you filmed it yeah like
9 12 or something like that he told the
story on stage oh really
he just and then he dropped it on
youtube yeah and i was like
what the [ __ ] how is this so good
yeah it's a worked out stand-up bit he
doesn't he does it on days other than 9
11. okay yeah so it doesn't diminish his
ability but i'm like but thank god this
isn't just something viral because he's
like it's wrong it's so punchy it seems
so [ __ ] in the moment because it says
do that on like a 30 minute special or
something since then and and it didn't
hit the same because the produ
views or no well they wanted it to be
different on the network they wanted to
change some of the things and the
original video he said he was like
actually just drunk in it and didn't
know that he was going to perform that
night and so there's some there's
where he's like saying some wild [ __ ]
and he goes i'm drunk
and it's like part of how funny the
whole thing is like it's those are the
authentic moments that i guess social
media is giving stand up now
heisenberg's principle of comedy is that
if you know a camera is on you won't
perform as well so that happens in new
york sometimes you do a set like we have
a tape of that you're like that's going
to be the best clip i'll ever post
because i didn't know there was a camera
there and i think i think chris yeah
like our conversation before this was so
so funny we were we were dude man i
can't believe we weren't rolling for
that [ __ ] what for like an hour no
but
yeah that that makes sense it it there's
a different pressure because then
sometimes it feels like
like if you go up and you and you you
maybe you go by yourself
too and this is where my experience is
you go by yourself you go up
you're doing your set for that room and
for yourself
to get better at stand up but when you
go up and you're maybe your buddies are
there and you know one of them's going
to film for you and stuff then
at a certain point you're you know that
you're doing this for either the video
i'm going to post this video i'm gonna
re-watch the video i'm gonna get a
screenshot of this for my instagram with
me on stage like it is it it's different
right here yeah yeah
i'm thinking about like how i'm
how i'm where they are sitting and like
how i'm going to be
in the video now i'm doing stand up for
a phone now i'm not doing it for the
room and i'm not doing it for myself in
a certain way yeah
i don't know if that's a good thing but
the with the clip world and all this
constant sharing of standup has
obviously
i'd say been a good thing what do you
think about that
oh i love that we
i do miss gatekeepers to some extent
because there's so much mediocrity just
being thrown at the internet uh in terms
of stand up and it does diminish the
product a bit
but cream always rises and
um it's fun it's fun because i do like
short jokes i do
i think if i can get a joke out to two
or three minutes i'm pretty excited if i
can if i can have one topic for four or
five minutes that feels really cool yeah
but sometimes i just write a stupid joke
that stands alone that never fits in my
act anywhere important never
tells any deeper story or conveys any
vulnerability and i just still like the
writing and that yeah what a great clip
to burn what a great 35 seconds for
reals
so do you are so you're you have a um a
writing process obviously do you write
things like that and go oh this will be
good for reals and then when whenever
you're out next make sure that you hit
on all those or are you still going
through maybe your regular sets and then
finding different moments to put unreal
much more the latter i don't ever write
for the intention of this is for this
and this is for that i just i just throw
out whatever's what i feel is funny when
it comes to me and maybe
look through my material during the day
and and rearrange stuff and plan a set
list and all that kind of stuff just to
see what comes out of it and then i'll
be doing a joke for a while i'm like
i'm like you know what i never thought
about that but that's a good real joke i
can pull that out it's very modular i
can take that out of that joke and the
joke is no weaker for it right um the
last set i did with comedy central
um
was the first set where i actually
consciously designed the whole set to be
fully modular where i could take out
every single joke and post it by itself
wow um every usually my goal has been
the opposite five minutes where you
can't tune out for
any joke because they all build within
one right theme or story or character
uh and this was like no it's good to
watch through and it builds
everything's gonna have an arc but like
this joke stands alone and great if you
just watch that and you like it i'm very
happy yeah that's a that seems more
difficult that's by far to be like
it's it's when you burn one of those one
of those perfect one-minute jokes you're
like well might be two years before i
write something of that quality yeah
it's that short and i'd like to know
that you could put it out there and it
could flop completely on the internet
even though it's a perfect joke like
just based on things outside your
control but you get so many shots you
get tick-tock and instagram and youtube
or you can put it in a late night set if
it falls flat you can keep doing it if
no one watches that's true you can you
can repost it a year later or six months
later i saw chris stefanos reposted that
bit every 9 11 since it happened
put it down take it back refractory
period is what we call that yeah uh
houston can you post a clip
um i it's here because i'm 10 10 or 11
years into comedy she doesn't feel that
long but the the when i started late
night sets were
what everyone was fighting for and they
could make people you could sell a show
because you had a hot set you could take
off
uh it could it could go viral and it was
it was about who could write five
minutes that this really shines as as a
unit as one functional piece five
minutes whatever that's 25 punch lines
maybe that's 50 punch lines closer call
back all that and
now i don't see much value in that
unfortunately uh for i mean i still
i see value in that it's really fun to
tell a joke like that in a room if i go
up there and just try to do a bunch of
40-second jokes i'll sputter out
eventually but the value of comedy is
still there
the internet now i mean you look at so
many great new york comedians who are
already writing in that super super
short joke smith style
and they're having a lot of success
which i'm very happy to see
uh because they have those perfect tick
tock jokes how do you think that
um the style of
of new york comedians it seems like they
they kind of all
fit in the same there there is a style
maybe you could put towards what it is
more but it seems like there is a style
of guys that you know were new york
comedians and guys that weren't if you
looked at them all not knowing anything
about them i feel like it'd be pretty
easy to pick out of a line highly highly
dense with punch lines uh very modular
some people are long long-form
storytellers but everything starts and
concludes mostly within a minute or two
sometimes three um
and
la and it's it's
like i think a to me a new york
stand-up is someone you could read their
sets and know where the punch lines are
and maybe even laugh out loud i call it
transcript comedy because the words do
the work already that's because you're
in a bar where people's attentions are
sure fans are shorter they're they're
expecting a lot out of the show because
it's new york cost a lot they know this
is a place where there's a lot of talent
um and it
yeah you can't waste words
whereas in la i mean i'm
i'm pretty judgmental of la just for the
not having had a great time living there
yeah but i see comics who sell their
character more than their words
and and perhaps there is a market for i
mean some some people that they just
want to see a funny person be funny i
want to see well-written jokes yeah
that's completely like i want to see a
singer with an amazing voice i'm like i
don't care the quality of the singer's
voice i'm going to hear a
well-constructed song yeah it's a matter
of personal preference um that is true
it almost like to a t seems like if i'm
just thinking of new york guys off the
top of my head and thinking imagining
their stand up and then la comedians off
the top like and i'm not even imagining
like a real set i'm just like picturing
my head like them on stage like what it
looks like very silly slow and and like
dalia was was to me is i'm talking to
pastors
[Music]
um he was kind of that guy who could you
could drive if you read a transcript of
his act you'll be like
yeah where's the laugh in this portion
yeah you watch like oh every six seconds
yeah yeah because he can say the same
phrase six times different ways yeah and
crazy i can't do that yeah i think
that's a real skill um i also think what
happens um is that in la no matter how
good you are there is much less stage
time there are you can be a successful
touring comedian and be doing three or
four spots a week and grateful for it
yeah and those are eight minute spots at
a bookstore uh or ten minute spots late
on a weeknight at a comedy club and
i feel to really figure out the the
writing of a joke you have to tell it a
hundred times to figure out oh that
little contraction is why it's one
little pause you have to do it so many
times and play with it you're like that
super simple wording has
just an iceberg underneath it of failed
attempts um whereas in la you don't get
that many attempts on it so how do you
pad out how do you how do you pump out
the amount of material well then you
just over act out the joke that makes a
ton of sense that's how you find the
laughs where you are unable to write
them that environment seems like it
would be it would lead to something like
like what you're saying gotta try harder
yeah and and and let's criticize new
york now the jokes pay off in 40 seconds
but things can can kind of just again
like i was saying sputter
after an hour of that pacing you need
something more like that you look at
good specials it's about half
observational and then the last 30 is
something that's more connected and then
the beats per minute slow down but then
they're getting it something more
personal more vulnerable that that kind
of
nanette was an example of that and and
you can criticize nanette but people who
are fans of hannah
are uber fans because she used she's she
gave up laughs per minute
uh in exchange for something more
personal and bigger than just comedy and
now she's gonna have their hands for
life too yes fans and you will never
figure out how to write like that right
if you're doing 15-minute spots around
new york city only you'll never have an
act like that well i feel like someone
beginning though like they would they
would think more like a new york comic
too like if you're a new comic that's
how you should be i really want to get
on stage i'm going to go more to like
something that like mark norman would
would write than something like
like hannah or
any of these storytellers like theo
van's a perfect example of someone that
is not transcribable for life no you'd
be like this is but he's an undeniably
funny person yeah yeah yeah so do you
think that those
or not do you think what would your
schedule be like
let's say you're not on the road
um it's a regular weekday do you line up
a spot every night multiple spots a
night um how do you how do you go about
kind of working out the these materials
and getting a joke to 100 reads in new
york um i
i just take all the spots i'm offered
which usually means
i like having monday or tuesday off i
like taking one weeknight off of comedy
if i have an empty day i don't look to
fill it on a weekday i'm like that's a
sign yeah um but one maybe two spots on
a weekday that's weekday being monday
tuesday wednesday thursday one or two or
three spots uh same with sunday it can
be a busy night and then saturday friday
saturday i hope i have
at least two
up to four and if i can arrange like if
i can find a place to pop in i'll do
that so
i think i end up with
usually 10 10 to 15 spots a week wow
what's your favorite place to perform at
i love uh
as much as i love the clubs of manhattan
and what a good feeling it is because
the crowds are so fun you're up with
great comics
i love the little bars
like out in brooklyn the bar shows where
it's 10 or 20 people okay and it's a
little more uh
they're they're more comedy savvy they
they seem to like when you look at the
notebook they seem to like the newer
jokes and you get it's just a good place
to try out stuff they understand they're
on the basis of creating something kind
of with you almost yes they get the
process because maybe they're artists
you know like uh like uh musicians or
something yeah cobra club has a show
called uh live from outer space micah
fox eric bergstrom and some other
producers i have so much fun every time
i'm there and it's a room that probably
only has about sometimes 20 sometimes
maybe 40 people there's comics in the
back and you can hear their laughs on
certain jokes versus the front
so that that's really fun to me because
that's where i tend to experiment the
most and how how are the clubs and your
regular places in the place that you
live compared to uh when you're on the
road
it's different uh clubs in new york the
clubs are different from each other but
you gotta you gotta swing you gotta you
gotta prove yourself immediately because
it's gonna be a strong lineup
in new york um
there's gonna be a lot of inside jokes i
can play too there's a lot of new york
jokes there's a lot of jokes i can only
do in new york yeah and i enjoy that i
enjoy a joke that only works here now
yeah i think the crowd i think a crowd
anywhere wants a joke you want you to
start with a joke
that cannot be oh picked up and moved to
another place yeah or there's a crowd
working with someone live
yeah give tailor this experience so that
we can tell you and copy paste it uh and
i can do that way better in new york
since i live there uh every time i've
been to side splitter since i've moved
here i think i've been three or four
times in every single time whether it's
been annie letterman joe list i saw
bob kelly there
everyone's done some sort of at the very
beginning like
something specific to tampa or like
florida in general like the florida man
or said some crazy stuff about
how i think every single person
mentioned that like oh you guys haven't
even had a pandemic here or something
like that it was a very like yeah and i
every time i was like
i i laughed a little more because i
could tell that it was it was uh not
written yeah
yeah yeah
everyone says that everyone says it
because they all get off from wherever
they were from usually like california
are like a stricter coveted area and are
like
oh it's so it was just it's normal here
yep it's it's funny yeah so people
definitely do
appreciate
something that they knew that you just
taylor made with yeah something bespoke
yeah uh and then i try to do it on the
road on the road i'm doing a longer set
so there's less flexibility in certain
ways where it's like if i want to do my
full set i have to there's portions of
jokes i need to include yeah extended
versions whereas in new york i'm only
doing 15. right so
do you think that if people came
they came to see you on the road and
let's say they're on a family vacation
to new york city and they see that you
are performing at some club and they're
like oh we saw them on the road let's
pop in would they be surprised by how
different the show is in the city with
these tighter
punch lines or would they just be like
oh that was just a different
type of show
that's a good question
i don't think it's that different
i think i am motivated by competition so
i will probably be like it'll be a it'll
be a
best hits compilation in
new york it'll be okay what can how can
i make myself as funny as possible in 15
minutes and cut out any fat yeah yeah
and just do a really words where it's in
a full length headline or sound like
let's just really explore uh let's
i mean i guess i'm saying the opposite i
just said but like
i try to in a 50-minute set include
um
something some portion in the middle
where i can work on the softer stuff
but there has to be bookmarking yeah
where it's like a great joke something
to work on if i have to if i have to if
i want to close the hour on this joke
then there's about 10 minutes of setup i
need
before i get to that closer right so
it's like okay is that the light i'll do
five minutes more of this and then i'll
start a 10 minute closing joke which
feels really suffocating sometimes that
makes a ton of sense yeah i guess i've
never really thought about it that that
kind of way and so you say that while
you're traveling around and try to like
customize jokes to to the different area
do you think that you as a traveling
headlining comedian have a better
understanding maybe on
just the country in general because it's
part of your job to always be moving
around and then also get to know
something about
yeah the areas to make a joke about i
mean we started this episode talking
about cities right yeah and i'm i don't
think i'm better at it like that's
that's a cocky thing to say but there
are certain things i really enjoy
analyzing about what makes this city's
culture different from this one and and
as comedians we get
the most wonderful polling data of why
does this joke when i say this get a
laugh here consistently if i do this
joke 100 times in new york city it will
get a laugh 91 percent of those times
yeah because if we do this joke in all
of florida it will get a laugh
12 percent
so what what variance we get and what is
that what does that speak to and i can
only hypothesize i'm not a scientist in
this but i can speculate as to what what
are the things that led to that yeah
what about the what about the heat and
the access to beaches and the higher
concentration of people uh what about
these non yeah i've never thought about
yeah
yeah fascinating yeah i mean beyond even
just the obvious i'm like well it's more
republican here like
what else can what if it's a
non-political joke what if it's the
stupidest joke ever it's a joke about
like [ __ ] corn dogs or something it
has nothing to do with any sides
what experiences do all these people
that live in this area with these
elements in these circumstances why is
their perspective on corn dogs so
different
than yeah that's so cool it's so cool to
me i mean yeah i love math i love
statistics and i think that comedy
the reason i'm drawn to it is i'm always
discouraged by subjective
pursuits
subjective creations because you'll
never have
equality you'll never have someone say
this is good this you can't grade it
like a test right most art the most
entertainment right whereas comedy where
like i heard the sound of laughter i
did something correct yeah so how can
something that is so subjective be so
consistent right
and then what are the variances within
that yeah yeah so i love that and i love
i want to figure out every city i could
do
i have so many regional jokes or
my austin joke i was just like let's put
this online this is such a this is such
a like you have to be from texas to get
this joke i put it online it was it was
cool to see other people like related to
it yeah
but that i have i have
three minutes on utah that i think is
wonderful and does not work even a
little bit outside of utah you're from
utah yeah that's crazy i've never
thought about
jokes like that that's that's
that's really cool actually there are
cheap moves and i do this but there are
jokes you can do about cities that sound
i say we've talked about jokes being
tailor made they can sound tailor made
and if you're a comic you're like yeah
that joke works in austin that joke also
works in portland that joke also works
yeah you can san francisco
yeah and and there's jokes you can do in
tampa that work in all of florida but
you can just say tampa yeah and there's
jokes at working in all of them you can
follow the south by you can do that in
texas you can use that louisiana yeah
that makes yeah i mean i guess i kind of
knew that but
it's fine it's still you know yeah
i do that like people are gonna be like
hey you know
that could also apply to mississippi
like to me the goal and this is my also
my goal with writing rose battle jokes
this is to me what what determines a
quality rose battle joke is
could you use it elsewhere
if the answer is no not even a little
bit my utah joke i am proud to say
only works about salt lake city yeah
that joke would i mean you could
slightly transfer it to boise but no it
works so specifically to that and that
makes me feel good whereas like a a rose
battle joke about someone being fat that
i could use on any other fat person
right it's not very satisfying no
because then you're just like writing a
joke you're you could have wrote that
without even knowing who the [ __ ] was
right just been like these are some fat
jokes i wrote and then here's some i
want something that ties together their
job yeah they look like and then me if
it can if it's like that's even better
if only i could tell
and that so that's basically the roast
battle version of going to a city and
saying a joke that only works for them
right like i want a joke that only works
for this between me and this other guy
except that yeah the one difference
being uh you jokes about a cities can
also complement those cities right which
is another thing i have learned the hard
way i'm from two cities where there
hasn't been any compliments boy when you
[ __ ] on a city people take it so
personally yeah man i did a joke in new
jersey where i got just chewed out by a
woman afterwards and then i wrote a
whole joke defending new jersey
as as a result that i've i took it so
hard that i'm like i'm gonna write
three minutes about how great new jersey
is and how people should stop [ __ ]
there's some comedians that have full-on
beefs with states like was tom segura
versus louisiana he had that great joke
about we should build the wall just
around louisiana yeah and people sent
him like death threats he said about it
they call him like racist against cajuns
how stupid cajuns are and i'm cajun i'm
like
solid like yeah i love just give us
representation and water boy wasn't
enough and it's a joke and it's a joke
but it's it's
i i really i i to a fault love to write
about regions and cultures and i also
moved a lot as a kid and i think that
that was a thing for me when i was i
lived in corpus christi texas and i just
had no idea that it wasn't a big town
yeah i just thought this was how
everyone lived i remember i watched like
john hughes movies with like the the
quarterbacks and the cheerleaders and
the nerds table and i was like well
that's not real right yeah my school's
mostly
uh
like i was
i i had a weird experience where i went
to a magnet school and they stuck us so
magnet school was a very different what
is a magnet school if you make a certain
i cheated you'd make a certain uh grade
on a test you get to go to like the
higher public school program where it's
like you know more
again yeah or athena program but then
what they do is they stick that program
into the lowest scoring school
because we are technically
that we become students of that school
and we buoy their test scores we believe
their graduation rates
but it it's um a
very tense thing because we have our own
classes
right in the athena program
this is going to sound racist but this
is the facts of the matter the athena
program was diverse it did a great job
of pulling from every racial background
the local school the public school we
were a part of was not
it happened to be in a city that is
mostly hispanic it was mostly hispanic
which meant there were plenty of
hispanic kids in the athena program um
but if you were white at that school you
most likely were part of the magnet
program
which the kids knew and the this is you
have your own classes but shared the
hallways in pe class so i was
a bullseye that's that's a key yeah
yeah i was i looked like a backup singer
for hansen i had like a blonde bowl cut
so i i was subject to that and there was
like there was like gangs at our middle
school
so that was what i experienced in corpus
and then my parents
uh my dad
retired or was forced to retire because
of medical things and we my mom wanted
to live anywhere but corpus we moved to
atlanta georgia
she stuck me in a very wealthy public
school for a year and that was john
hughes high school that was uh the
football players were there their
t-shirts like yeah they're getting out
of here squeak yeah they're mostly white
they're carrying their football with
them
[Music]
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is this
this is real and and just such a
hierarchy of popularity because it was
such a big i was also my school was
small there was no room for clicks
really yeah i was i hung out with like
the weird theater kids and then the math
kids seems like you guys were
accidentally a click by yourself though
in this in this yeah yeah they were kids
it was actually it was really cool to
see the the magnet kids who could hang
out with the the local kids right that
took a lot of social skills to pull off
um but then and then i spent a year
there and it was such a culture shock
for me to see that that was real and
then i got my parents sent me to a
private school
that put the public school to shame in
terms of wealth
and pretentiousness one thing i noticed
was the public schools you were all over
the yeah i got to see the full gamut of
of how wealth not i guess i didn't see
the poorest but right i got to see
pretty poor to very very rich about how
different well then you get now you have
all this perspective if you just take
yourself out of those experiences of now
you know how half the country is
educated
yeah
and uh also seeing corpus versus atlanta
and i went to college in houston which i
got to live in the city which made me
realize i'd never lived in a city
because my college was like in and then
i lived there and then i moved to l.a
and i so at that point i was only a
southerner and i'm jewish and i come
from a family that really values
education and i was kind of fed a lot of
uh propaganda about how the south is an
uneducated intolerant and backwards
place but while you were there yeah my
mom hated it there so she constantly was
just [ __ ] on it and i'm going to
move i figured la would be a progressive
place more jews more transplants
and i found it to be
monolithic culturally at least la
and i found it to be less educated than
houston
and um
and made me more defensive of the south
because houston had nasa houston has the
world's biggest medical district houston
has like
all of the petrochemical engineers all
the oils are based there so i realized i
had been performing to really educated
crowds when i got to la i was like oh
these are just people with film degrees
wow and they're all kind of if there's a
there's a base level of
i mean i've never been to la so but from
what i've gathered is of pretentiousness
or just like cutthroat maybe
self-centeredness out there where it's
like it's pretty accurate it's it's like
in texas
and it seems to be more
there's there's giving or
laid back even or just that's
that's just that's interesting that you
were talking about your the crowds
though that you get to perform to i love
how that affects it i didn't i didn't i
realized so much later how much that you
think it's because they're at because of
their education level
and maybe you have a high level act
maybe of of like your jokes or your
references or do you think that no
matter what your act was if you had the
silliest most nonsensical act versus the
most prolific like thought out i'm
making good points do you think that the
education level
plays in to
to that like from the audience or yeah
education will always or or education's
bad because not everyone has access to
education i think curiosity is a better
word
which i consider a very high virtue that
people who seek to know new things
rather than just uh be placated by by
things they already agree with and
especially if you're doing observational
jokes if you're not curious then they're
not going to make any sense or it's
going to be harder for it to make sense
there's jokes that kill that everyone
laughs but then there's people that
don't get it and they're sitting there
for three four more seconds until
they're like oh
that's what he meant because it's
something just so strange so what's such
a weird observation so
i would say those three four seconds is
probably your curiosity just
lagging behind almost that is a good
feeling when you tell a joke and it
takes a second to click and then you get
people laughing at different points that
is my favorite feeling it's the best
because in the world the first people
that get it those are like your boys and
you're like all right now i know it
wasn't dumb at least what i said so now
i have the confidence to be like almost
smug to the people falling behind
because in their head they might be like
that joke was i'm assuming that they're
thinking that joke was dumb but then i'm
like you're not going to think that if
you you know just wait wait a little bit
and i'm going to change your own mind
yeah that's a good feeling
the people who left first like that okay
those people were with me and and seeing
where the joke was going and and found i
gave them enough information they put
together very quickly
and then there's the second wave of
people who laugh who took longer to put
together and now the first wave of
laughers are realizing that other people
got it slower and now they're laughing
at them
and now those people are laughing at
themselves so it just creates this this
yeah kind of this organism that's out of
your control now yeah that feels very
nice and then you can stoke the flame by
throwing in like oh some people just got
it and now you're the first guy right
like with you more kind of a cheap move
but like are you finally oh yeah
well i think we're probably nathan where
are we closing on an hour here or so
[Music]
50 minutes um [ __ ] 10 more minutes
jesus christ
i think
yeah
and just because of the wrap up i feel
like now i just got to go through with
the closing but thank you for uh letting
me come steal you away from your grocery
shopping so thank you for showing me
real tampa oh yeah holiday express
yeah uh side splitters tonight
um i'm not sure i don't know how long
we'll hold on to this one but just plug
anything that you want yourself
may 18th through 21st uh i'll be making
my debut at the san francisco punch line
um that's the one i'll plug for now and
then i'm at monday pundit on all my
platforms monday monday my youtube's on
stand-ups uh my stand-up's on youtube
because so
all right well matthew thank you again
thank you so much man thanks for
supporting me monday for sure uh all
right i don't really know how to end it
so i'll probably just keep christmas
here
[Music]
thank you man that was fun that was fun
[Music]
you